ooh you want to get a fight phone usage
for kids
i don't think we've ever talked about
this phone usage for kids
what is my rules for phone usage for
kids what's yours james
um my kid oh that was a good that was a
good
i i would have prepared for this if i'd
known you were going to toss us so many
questions
uh our kids don't use phones and they
won't for as long as
i can help it yeah but also i don't want
to i don't want to just jump in and
not have any experience and health you
know healthy boundaries with it so
um actually that's not true they use
phones for they shoot home movies all
the time with old
our old phones so but they're not like
on social media or on the internet or
anything
yeah we started we let our
our son have a phone when he started
coming home by himself
because we don't have a home phone but
we started with
um so 25 a month was worth the soul of
your child i could see that yeah you
know
but uh give and take him we
started with just only an old phone with
no sim card
and then when he turned i think 15 we
let him but i am
all up in it i look through it all the
time he knows that
i'll come up and grab it when he's
talking you know looking scrolling
i'm and i mean my husband's i.t so he
can't get away with much he can't get
away with anything
yeah so my rule of thumb get this
my son's in fifth grade he came home a
few weeks ago
a hundred percent of the kids in his
class
not only have smartphones they're ten
they all have these tick tock accounts
and they all are
hanging out back and forth and it he
discovered
live he's been left out of all this
stuff
it was hard but the hardest thing was
i thought i'd know what's going on this
is
madness that a 10 year old has that kind
of access
so in my house man like i'm i'm like
james
james and i are clearly better parents
than kelly but um no
yeah no our kids aren't as old as
kelly's yet yeah come on the
listeners don't be a teenager now my son
has no social media and he will not
for quite some time that's not even
man the data is so clear if you have a
10 year old don't let him have social
media
there's a 15 year old don't let them no
no it's in this era of digital
babysitters
they're growing up being babysat by
other fifth graders
it it's just insane it's insane so
i i will hand them a phone if they are
facetiming like their grandparents
grandparents or an aunt or something
like that and we do have old phones like
you guys have
um where they download books in the
library like books they can listen to
audio books
but other than that they don't even ask
it's it's the
the data is so clear on how destructive
this is for kids
and now we're in a world where a 12 year
old says something texts something
and it's going to keep him from getting
a job when he's 40. and i want my kids
to be
kids as long as they can be um it's just
gotten very
unforgiving the world overnight and so
it's just
it's just not worth the risk um we have
talked about kelly this is awesome
i was on a ladder it was just me and my
son was at home and i
took a step in the ladder i mean it was
like
i thought oh this is it i'm coming down
and because
i'm part ninja i stopped it that's not
at all it just stopped
miraculously and my son was looking at
me his eyes were really wide and he was
probably five or six and i said
if i had just fallen and gotten hurt
what would you have done
and he looked at me for a second and
sprinted to his room and got an
old trashed cracked like plastic flip
phone and he's like i would have called
9-1-1 and i was like man i'd be dead
right
so we've talked about getting a landline
we just haven't done it but we're gonna
do that soon